snella faster than the police allowed
that is something we expect from the
high-performance tuner Bravo's when it
comes to the smart it's a bit different
it's a city car and not very fast
nearly generations in particular were
not renowned for speed
still smart and Bravo's have worked
together for 15 years now and they say
you could even go racing with the latest
smart bravo site let's see what it can
do
Bravo's has turned up the power more
than 20% more in this racy racing
version that in a regular smart with the
biggest 66 kilowatt or 90 horsepower
engine that boost takes more than a
tweaking of the software
Kristopher schulenburg Oh smart explains
how they found almost 20 horsepower more
Braavos reduced the exhaust back
pressure and raised the boost pressure
in the turbocharger to give it a sporty
ride brah booze cut gearshift times by
up to 40% made the steering more
responsive and adjust to the triggering
thresholds and the electronic stability
program the suspension is 20% taught
herb than in the regular models when you
corner fast it almost feels like you're
driving a go-kart our car tester Montes
says that a go-kart would hug the road a
bit more oh here comes another she came
it's pushing a bit on the front wheels
but that's not too bad and you notice
that in good time
so Marquez feels pretty much in control
here on the racetrack he would like to
see more lateral support in the seats
though they are more suited for long
trips than racetracks still it's great
fun zipping around this course he says
laugh out loud fun
of course you can't compare a smart
Braavos with a real sports car in terms
of performance but why should you it is
more about fast fun than competitive
racing at any rate it makes you want to
just keep on going round the track he
says but the smart Braavos is designed
to be fun both on the track and a good
means of transport on the streets of the
city says so let's turn our attention to
that now
the exterior is not the same as that of
its mass-produced siblings
it has different aerodynamics and a
brawny ER in-your-face look
on the road it is still zippy but more
sedate than on the track there just
aren't the same curves here
mata says you have different
requirements on a country road and on a
racetrack the very sensitive steering is
great on the track but too responsive
almost jumpy on the road on the other
hand the seats don't give you enough
support on the track but are just fine
under normal driving conditions with 170
Newton meters of torque
you can charge out of a curve smartly it
is anything but dull cruising through
the countryside we can take a moment to
inspect the interior Montes likes the
mix of leather and fabric on the
dashboard the smooth Braavos may have
been souped up but it's not a guzzler
fuel consumption is just a tad higher
than in the series production models
the smart Bravo's also behaves very well
on the motorway while the regular smarts
come with manual transmission the smart
BRABUS comes only with a specially tuned
dual clutch transmission with additional
levers on the steering wheels to change
gear manually says Montes but that is
really more suited to the track than the
real world the gears shift so well by
themselves you really don't need to get
involved this smart is so good you could
go far with it except isn't there that
issue with the steering
oh man could did what Montes said about
the steering being jumpy on a country
road well that does not apply on the
motorway even at high speed the maximum
is given at 165 kilometers an hour
there's no problem with staying in your
lane even though you might make an
unintentional maneuver with a steering
wheel it is really good but we should
not forget that the smart is basically
an originally a town car the BRABUS
version has the same modest turning
circle of under 7 metres and it is so
elegant it blends right in here in
snazzy downtown Dusseldorf all that
power has to be kept in check in city
traffic says Montes if you feel the need
to keep up with the posh limos here it
will be the stylish bodywork that
doesn't a universal problem for
motorists is finding a parking place
they are in short supply almost
everywhere
in that respect it is great that the
smart is so short so in theory it should
be easier to find a parking spot but in
practice that would only work if
everybody else drove was smart as well
smart fortwo fun then it does Orpington
yet mine so to sum up the smart fortwo
obviously won't do for a family of four
since it only has two seats in a tiny
trunk but for in town it is cool and it
is smart it's Swift on the track too and
for long distances it is a comfortable
way to get from A to B